botes como estos navegan por el mar
Mediterráneo a bordo migrantes que
buscan mejores oportunidades en Europa y
el escenario la ruta más letal para el
tránsito desde 2014 más de 25.000
migrantes desaparecieron en la travesía
y en 2022 esa cifra casi alcanza los
2000 el del Mediterráneo Central es el
trayecto por el que más se embarcan
desde las costas africanas en 2022 el
número de cruces fronterizos irregulares
detectados por frontex la guardia de
fronteras europea aumentó en un
49%, es decir fueron casi 94.000
personas en tránsito por el Mediterráneo
central la mayoría de migrantes que
atravesaron por esa ruta en 2022
salieron de Egipto túnez y Siria al
rescate nuevamente estuvieron las
organizaciones No gubernamentales que
enfrentaron los mismos desafíos
hacinamientos encubierta y la negativa
de los países europeos para garantizar
un puerto seguro
actualmente estamos en una posición de
enfrentamiento en aguas internacionales
de sicilia con 234 mujeres hombres y
niños a bordo entre ellos El
Sobreviviente más joven tiene tres años
y tenemos más de 40 menores no
acompañados que viajan solos
y la respuesta humanitaria sigue como un
pendiente el tema migratorio durante el
último año enfrentó a gobiernos como el
de Francia e Italia y volvió a dejar
Clara la radical posición de este último
país frente al tema y desde 2015 sigue
en el aire una respuesta Europea
conjunta